президент України Петра Порошенка входи
до десятки на багатих людей України
зарізаним відтінком та їх залишки
встановлено близько мільярда доларів
про свій бізнес то передвиборні танки
порошенку розправивши дойче велле про
програмі конфлікт на зонах інтерв'ю
води та цифрам дуже жорстку розмову cool
та видачею перебуваючи за право кістку та
можливий кота ставити він з ручним за
харчуванням закри проп'є і канал рикки
даси
накласти порошенку а я нещодавно петя брешу
дати 5 канал
цим ніколи вбити різанина до сім'ядольних
архів річки володіють українською мовою on
different
і версії яви зізнайся і ще випади
намагайся 5 канал вино dance ти хто
найбільшою критику та
і один знай лише винних там журналісти з
репутації та створивши і вчора у сфері
ракети був journalist м вальс урану
річчю вином b-tribe
навіщу ви призи для вас потрібною шукаємо і
справа ми позики тис у кого ществ
проїжджаєте витал і канал у Європі вони та
a bigger and i were freedom of ps я
гарант свободи преси та стандарти
журналістів на п'ятому каналі
його кликають критики та 100 сумки між
мною і журналістам і абсолютно в ганьбі
та клубі
абсолютно рнк between вами джон доставка
save та головний актив шоколадний бізнес та
президент так і не продав за крима
кондитерську фабрику рошен посмішку за
слово моє порошенко часті але його бізнесу
у Росії конфіскував і
їм якісно педарі що там у мене моя
купівля пояс ними президент але свої
українські активи заповнюючи порошенку
вінтаж і не спливаючи md only та україні
я єдиний український президент та гепардів
свої акти видано закладено трастового
фонду завидну репутацію та я думаю ще з
по-європейськи коли країни в стані війни
і ніхто не хоче купувати ти бізнес хоч
так розділ id та бізнес та політику is the
separate бізнес
адже povestea президент задоволення але
за харчування про гаманців та батальйони та
key для vista і у мене своїх інтересів з
творив і українські олігархи